Scott Galloway taught me 50 of democrat
parents fear that their child will marry
a Republican
you don't even feel ashamed right if you
try political bias Against Racism people
are way more politically racist than
they are racially racist it's true and
yet we don't care as much about that one
for some reason the interesting thing
there is that your politics tell me a
lot more about you than your race they
tell me more about your worldview at
least how you show up in the world
probably than your race it's the same
reason in the UK that people are more
prejudiced against those with different
accents than those with different skin
colors this is a study that was done
that was really interesting and quite
rightly like somebody walks into a room
that is of A different race to you but
speaks in a similar accent you have an
awful lot more in common with that
person than someone who walks into the
room with the same skin color as you but
a different accent right especially in
the UK and I learned this from someone
who was British the UK's got such a
rigid class system and accent denotes an
awful lot of that class